foreign
[Music]
we are back and we have been building
this brand new studio with people often
said Dave we want to see more of you
actually that's a totally different type
of show and then obviously I said too
much and I'm not exactly sure what I
said that was bad no one ever told me
but one day they're like oh can't have
this anymore and they fired me and
that's why Independent Media scares the
F out of the machine Strike Force Five
is the name of our podcast subscribe to
it now
can you imagine anything worse than that
I can't
[Music]
how that man didn't go home right after
that open up his mouth a gun and
blow his brains out you're not gonna get
covered if you have these vaccinations
Jill Biden Dr Jill Biden she has covid
she's double faxed and double boosted
and she has Coke literally every bit of
it was nonsense and therefore while not
forcing anyone
to get vaccinated enforcement measures
in place will make sure
that everyone is vaccinated there was no
there was no compulsory vaccination
people made their own choices and so
follow
customers must be vaccinated then so too
must the workers if you are vaccinated
you are fighting I am not going to have
your freakish blood anywhere near me
that's the way we're doing it okay I'm
not risking it I've got kids now I can't
have you weirdos near me foreign
people it is September 6 2023 I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals share subscribe tap that
notification Bell if you have not we got
a post game show over at
reubenreport.locals.com for our paid
subscribers and you can also chat with
the team during the show if you'd like
to join us if you want to get me
information correct me or anything else
live on air it's all possible but you
got to be a member of
reubenreport.locals.com it is day two in
the new studio you know I said to you
guys yesterday that some of this were
still changing on the Fly we have a
couple new camera angles that will be
coming in soon there's a camera angle
for you right there we're gonna have a
sliding camera do we have the ability to
slide that thing today or we'll debut
that maybe tomorrow couple days we will
have a moving camera all sorts of stuff
is happening but as I mentioned to you
guys yesterday we wanted to hear some of
your feedback on this which I was
thrilled to see that everyone really
really loved it a couple people did
mention some things so we have a new
light shining up on me right now so it's
a little more balanced we also added a
lightwear over here on the wood wall
over here uh and uh we're working it all
through so I thank you for your patience
and I'm really glad that everyone's
digging it oh and I also want to mention
that this uh painting right here uh a
lot of people ask about that that is the
print it's called arrete it is a print
the original is actually in my house a
brilliant artist Kalyn Rose Janet you
can go to kalinrosejanet.com uh I have
the original in my house but this is a
print of that and you can get that print
if you want Kalyn Rose Janet
c-a-y-l-i-n-rosejanet.com we will put
her info in the description I don't want
any cash off that that's just uh some
nice artwork in your home before we get
to the Big Show today I want to mention
something that happened yesterday as we
were as we were doing the show we played
you a clip of RFK Jr and he uh mentioned
how that the CIA basically is placing
people at Big Time
news organizations places of Journalism
air quote you got it places like The
Daily Beast and places like Rolling
Stone etc etc and he mentioned
specifically this guy Noah shackman who
was once the editor-in-chief of Daily
Beast and I think now is the
editor-in-chief of Rolling Stone if I'm
not mistaken and when I heard him say
that I go wait a minute I've been in
fights with this guy this guy has
written many things about me and called
me and my friends lots of mean things
and we were looking for the Tweet we
found it so I want to show you this look
at this this is five years ago this guy
Noah shackman who at that time was the
editor-in-chief of the Bailey The Daily
Beast they called me an alt-right
cheerleader they included of course
Glenn Beck in that and Stephen Crowder
other articles included Jordan Peterson
and many others I got into a big Twitter
spat with this guy I mentioned this as I
often say on this show not to make this
about me but now I want to throw you I
want to throw to you this clip of RFK Jr
saying that this guy shackman who was
calling people like me and Crowder and
Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson all
right and alt-right adjacent and
alt-right cheerleaders and everything
else apparently he's in bed with the CIA
listen to RFK
there's a provision of the CIA Charter
that says that the CIA cannot propaganda
I see American people President Obama
adopted in 2016.
that essentially reopened the door for
operation Mockingbird so that the CIA
began once again to um to propaganda as
American how are they doing that
President high level intelligence
officials are or people associated with
the intelligent industry
are running those journals like Noah
schlachmann who runs a linkstone who
came from Daily Beast Daily Beast was
run by John Avalon who was you know who
has deep ties to the intelligence
agencies I mean is that connected to
everything else that we talk about on
this show or what again not making it
about me but this guy who RFK Jr and let
RFK Jr's words stand on their own if you
can if you can punch holes in it if you
can prove that he's a conspiracy
theorist or a liar please send us some
info and we'll go he is saying that this
guy Noah shackman has connections with
the CIA and the FBI and they basically
they placed people to run
Daily Beast Rolling Stone he talks about
Washington Post uh he talks about New
York Times etc etc to push propaganda on
the American people that operation
Mockingbird that that's exactly what it
was designed to do and Obama allowed it
to once again be pushed on the American
people so it makes you wonder why would
our intelligence ages agencies place a
guy like this Noah fella at say The
Daily Beast or Rolling Stone to then
write really awful things alt-right
cheerleader Dave Rubin I mean that's
basically saying Nazi that's what they
were trying to say five years ago about
me you think this is connected to the
things they say about Trump supporters
anyone who fights the woke mob
Etc you get it we shall obviously
continue to talk about this more but the
theme of today's program is human nature
and The Human Condition because as I
often talk about on this show one way or
another you end up believing in
something there are an awful lot of
people
who want to think that they are so
evolved they are so smart and so bright
and we are so modern in our thinking
that they don't worship anything at all
right that through their own thinking
they can come up with with the reality
of the nature of the universe uh I don't
agree with that I don't agree with that
there was a time in my life where I
guess I did agree with that or I was one
of those people but it has become fairly
obvious to me especially over the last
couple years especially after watching
covet tyranny uh envelope basically all
of our institutions and our sense-making
apparatus that if you do not worship
something usually known as God that you
will end up worshiping basically
anything and what usually steps into
that vacuum is government power now I
mentioned this today because it has
become fairly obvious over the last
couple days that kovid 2 is on the way
and it's on the way just in time yeah
for the election which is just over a
year from now they seem to want to bring
covid back they seem to want to bring
masks back and more injections back and
everything else and I for one am not
going to have it I hope you will not
have it either let's talk about Patriot
Supply real quick and then we'll unpack
all of the nonsense that they are about
to unpack on us do you guys get the
feeling that something bad is about to
happen soon man this ad really nailed it
for us today uh I certainly do but
between the distractions and smoke
screens in the media we probably won't
see it coming that's why it's smart to
invest in emergency food right away as
they say it's better to have it and not
need it than to need it and not have it
my Patriot Supply is the nation's leader
in high quality emergency food head over
to my website
preparewithrubin.com and you'll save 200
on your three-month emergency food kit
from my Patriot Supply enjoy it enjoy a
wide variety of delicious meals offering
over 2 000 calories every day for
Optimum strength under stress stock up
before Panic sets in free shipping is
automatic and your order ships fast go
to prepare with reuben.com that's
prepare with reuben.com and now back to
me all right so let's go into what the
machine is pushing on us and actually
why they're pushing it on us and what
the mental state of the people who
consistently get duped by the machine
and then ask for more of it is actually
all about here is Tucker Carlson
on what the average Democrat voter is
like
the ruling party is the party of the
childless the unmarried the people who
are working for low wages for large
corporations and living in tiny
apartments and overcrowded cities that
are Rife with crime working for big
non-profits or big Banks living in
crowded conditions very often alone in
big soulless cities spending their time
glued to a screen what does that sound
like to you it sounds like prison
actually well that's the life of your
average Democratic voter okay so he's
being a little glib there but I would
say it's just a little glib you know we
usually talk about the red blue divide
right yeah right we have Democrat States
and Republican states and certainly over
the last few years of kobit we've seen a
wider Chasm between those things and I
would say that's actually a beautiful
thing because the experiment of America
is if you don't like the high taxes and
the ridiculous government oversight and
overreach in say a place like California
you can move to a place like the free
state of Florida and somehow without any
income tax here in Florida we still have
roads it's really bizarre okay that's
one thing but the other piece that's not
purely connected to like red blue is the
way people live and that's what Tucker
is talking about that in these blue
cities because almost all of our big
cities are blue right New York City San
Francisco Los Angeles Chicago these are
cities that have been run by democrats
for decade after decade after decade
occasionally like in New York City you
get a little red blip like Rudy Giuliani
and that then uh causes an incredible
economic expansion and cultural
expansion which then of course you get
uh Democrat socialists like Bill de
Blasio who come in after a guy like
Giuliani and ruin the entire thing but
the difference really is not just
Republican Democrat uh liberal
conservative it's that the people that
live in big cities versus the people
that live in the rest of the country and
I don't mean just that you're living on
a ranch in Montana if you just like live
a little bit outside of city if you have
a little bit of land if you can grow a
little bit of food if you're just a
little a little bit out of the
day-to-day
endless churning craziness of the city
you become less reliant on the machine
the Democrats really love people who are
reliant on the machine they want to tell
you what to think they want to regulate
what soda you can or cannot have what
you're injecting in yourself whether
you'll go to school what you will learn
at that school
etc etc
and this is directly related to the fact
that most of the Democrat Party at this
point the base is purely sort of
secularism on steroids now again I'm not
telling every I'm not telling anyone
actually what to believe or how to
worship or anything else but to get
again to the thesis if you don't believe
in something you will just believe in
exactly what is happening
right now and you will look for answers
from people who actually don't have any
answers at all here's a bit on that from
my friend Russell Brandt when it says in
the Old Testament worship no other gods
than me
the implication I offer is that we are a
species that worships and if you do not
access the Divine you will worship the
Mundial you will worship the profane you
will worship your own identity you will
worship your belongings you will worship
the template Lane Before You by a
culture that wants you no wants you that
gets you distracted and relatively done
okay so what's interesting about that is
okay he's he's laying out something
similar to what I've laid out here I
don't think there's anything wrong with
material things I don't think there's
anything wrong with capitalism I don't
think there's wrong with having a big
house or the cars you want or whatever
your boat or yacht whatever you want but
that cannot be the sum totality of
everything right it just simply cannot
be but once you disconnect
belief in something other than What's
Happening Here Right Here and Now then
when weird things happen say covet say
they just tell you there's a pandemic
whether it's real or it's not you will
end up worshiping
the power that you've ceded to them
right you will worship the people who
somehow seem like the expert class a
perfect example of that I think we
showed you this video yesterday it's
very short is a guy like Anthony fauci
who will not only be responsible for
covid
through gain of function research that
we were funding NIH was funding he was
funding at the Wuhan lab not only
responsible for it but then we'll get
everything wrong throughout it and
people will still listen to him time and
again
first of all I didn't recommend locking
anything down and the record will show
Neil that we didn't recommend shutting
everything down I recommended to the
president that we shut the country down
and that was very difficult decision
because I knew it would have serious
Economic Consequences which it did the
guys just made note we actually didn't
show you that video yesterday we had it
in our rundown and we dropped it at the
last second but you get the point that
these people once you say oh fauci is
automatically a good man that these are
the good people who will tell us how to
live and all of those things they will
keep getting things wrong but a certain
set of people will keep following the
crumbs that they are laying out behind
them so what is the point of all of this
well the irrationality the fear that
they instill into everybody starts
becoming what our actual sort of
cultural
what our what our cultural norms are if
if everything they tell us is to be
afraid and to be angry and to be pissed
and hate the other and be afraid of
going outside and all of these things it
starts doing something to our very Souls
which then how long can a society last
like that so we thought this video is
interesting uh this is a video uh in the
first few weeks right before covid
really blew up so this is March of 2020
right before lockdowns right before mask
mandates a bit before injections and all
of that this is Rachel Maddow now listen
to her sort of calmly at this point and
this is very different than The Rachel
Maddow we've come to know in the last
couple years but right before covid sort
of calmly explaining what might happen
with covid it's likely to spread around
the entire world a lot of people are
going to get it potentially most of the
world's population are going to get it
which sounds terrible but it of most of
the people who get coronavirus will not
die from it okay um it's got about a two
percent fatality rate
um and the way that we all need to deal
with it although it is a new threat
we've never seen this virus before it's
actually very old-fashioned ways of
protecting ourselves you do all the
things that you do to protect yourself
from getting a cold or from getting the
flu we don't have to do anything
outrageous we don't need to change our
lives drastically at an individual level
you just need to be more Vigilant about
washing your hands make sure you don't
develop patterns where you don't touch
your face that's the way that we tend to
give ourselves colds in the flu so on an
individual level for some reason to
panic but it's a serious thing I saw
somewhere they said don't sneeze or
cough on people I go
exactly were people doing that New
Year's resolutions I gotta stop coughing
on people I really am not getting
invited back to parties yeah I've seen a
lot of The Masks around the city is that
that's probably not a not a thing
um I mean you're seeing it but it's
probably not that smart the Surgeon
General actually put out a statement
which was like you guys stop buying
masks if you are sick if you have
respiratory symptoms that's people are
wearing a mask in that circumstance
because you're trying to avoid giving it
to other people but in terms of being a
healthy person and trying to avoid
getting infected that's probably not not
that right yeah isn't that wild like
relative to everything we know of Rachel
Maddow and now we're going to show you a
clip of her going crazy during covid
which is more consistent with The Rachel
Maddow that you guys know isn't that
wild right before Oh we could just deal
with this the way that we've dealt with
the cold and the flu let's not go crazy
with masks or anything like that you
know try not to sneeze on somebody like
there was this calmness they could joke
about it and all that but then everyone
starts seeding power to the machine
seeding power to the bureaucrats like
fauci to the media members like Mado
herself and then they start going crazy
on power here is Rachel Maddow just 13
months later in April of 2021.
it is okay to feel reluctant or Oogie or
scared and not want to get it that is
nothing to be ashamed of
but feel the fear and do it anyway get
it
because most of all it is not for you it
is to keep you from getting it and then
spreading it
seriously if I can get it and like have
such an emotional release from the fear
and anxiety and relief and gratitude
about it that I can cry through it like
a baby in front of lots and lots of
other people including lots of people in
uniform if I can do it you can do it
I do not recommend this angle for your
selfie nor do I recommend wearing a hat
with a binder clip on the brim
but you can do it
if I can do it you can do it
so remember guys before covid right
before she realized that this was going
to be able to be a major power grab
before many people like her it's
certainly not just her it's not just the
members of the media and the bureaucrats
like fauci it's the politicians and all
of the people who grabbed whatever they
could to control you in whatever way
they could the people who were selling
masks whatever it might be they went
from calm and cool and collected to that
we showed you the video yesterday which
we've shown you many times before I've
heard telling you for a fact if you get
that vaccine you ain't gonna get nor
transmit covid just like Joe Biden said
right of course Joe Biden's wife Jill
Biden has coveted right now as you know
so why am I taking this trip down memory
lane well it is becoming fairly obvious
that they
excuse me I'm choking while I'm doing
this that they are bringing kovid back
because we have this election and God
knows what else they will bring back or
they're just running the test on us or
or whatever else uh and we cannot fall
for it again so we'll get to that on the
other side let me talk to you about
moink box real quick uh you guys know
that 60 of U.S pork production comes
from one company owned by the Chinese
and their Hogs are given something
called ractopamine which is banned in
160 countries including China yet you
find it in your grocery aisle every day
there's a better way guys and I want to
tell you about moink that's moo plus
oink I haven't said that in a while
moink delivers grass fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door more Farmers Farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because the
Family Farm just does it better the
moink difference is the difference you
can taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping Family Farms stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered never every
box like rib eyes chicken breasts to
pork chops to salmon fillets and much
more you can cancel any time and Shark
Tank host Kevin O'Leary called moink's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
plus ladies and gentlemen they guarantee
you'll say oink oink I'm just so happy I
got mocked keep American farming going
by signing up at moinkbox.com Reuben
right now and listeners of this show get
free ground beef for a year that's one
of the best ground beef you'll ever
taste but for a limited time
m-o-i-n-kbox.com reubenmoinkbox.com
Reuben and now back to me okay so are
they bringing covid back well it sort of
seems like it uh yesterday on our show
because the view is on at the same time
as us Brock let me know that live on The
View they announced that whoopee has
cookie
um as you can see Whoopi is not here she
has covid
yes it's back it's back it's back but
she's on the mend she's on the tail end
and she'll probably be back this week
but sorry she's not here for those of
you who are looking forward to seeing
her
whoopee has covered
foreign
Joy is like oh she'll be back in a
couple days it's like what happened to
you gotta lock down you gotta stay in a
room you gotta wrap a plastic bag around
your head with duct tape and the whole
thing anyway so okay that's just Whoopi
having covet at the season debut of the
view but it does seem like the machine
is kind of trying to scare everybody you
guys know CNN's resident Dr Sanjay Gupta
here's what he tweeted out yesterday
because schools are starting up he wrote
schools around the country are back in
session just in time for respiratory
virus season what are your back to
school questions when it comes to
covid-19 RSV or flu I'll try to answer
as many questions as possible this
Wednesday on CNN this morning so yes it
is the fall and people do tend to get a
little more sick in the fall because the
weather is changing it's a little cooler
in most of the country and yes kids that
are around each other
back in my day I'm a child of the 80s
you'd go to school somebody might be
sick they might take a day off everybody
would deal with it your teacher might be
sick you'd have a substitute teacher you
didn't close school down you didn't shut
kids out for a year and everything else
but anytime I think of Sanjay Gupta I'm
always reminded of this important uh
message that he let us all know a couple
years back you may remember this there
are stories circulating on the internet
that in India and elsewhere the drug rib
of Aaron has been shown to be effective
against this virus yet Homeland Security
is telling the CDC not to make any
announcements until stockpiles the drug
can be secure the Doctor Gupta there
continue to be evaluations of several
drugs ribavarian is among them
but right now our best defense has been
social distancing no handshaking staying
home when you're sick washing your hands
frequently
you see what we just did there guys uh
Sanjay Gupta and they even referred to
him as Dr Gupta in that uh sitting
across over there from what's that
Lawrence Fishburn yeah that's from the
movie Contagion before covet ever came
out there so it's contagion it's an
absolutely spectacular movie by the way
uh but before kovid there was the movie
Contagion and Sanjay Gupta was playing
Sanjay Gupta talking about an imaginary
drug and social distancing and not
touching people and everything else
these people are actors they are actors
and we have put actors in charge of our
lives and I took an acting class
actually about 15 years ago and I can
tell you this for sure actors are morons
but speaking of morons actually and
people that shouldn't be in charge uh
clay Travis tweeted this that wasn't a
shot of clay Travis this is a shot at
the people that he's referencing
speaking of morons here's clay Travis no
I love you clay I love you clay uh clay
saw this a DC area Elementary School
Montgomery County Maryland is
reinstating a mask mandate n95s for
third graders over a few kids testing
positive for covid here's the letter
they're coming with masks for your kids
again get ready read this insanity and
then he uh he screen captures the whole
thing right there guys once again as we
referenced yesterday
masks do not work okay even n95 masks
most likely don't work and even if they
did the damage you are doing especially
to a young person a third grader putting
them in this thing I cannot believe this
is where we're at again but the damage
you're gonna put them like they're Bane
at least Bane could breathe through that
day but the damage they can't see their
friends they can't smile they just bow
to the system they become little cogs in
a machine it is just so evil and I
wanted to mention this one we showed you
this one yesterday but just real quick
from Jay battachary over at Stanford
it's not just uh elementary schools in
Maryland it's places like University of
Michigan at the University of Michigan
students testing covid positive must
leave their dorms for five days and live
in the community a hotel room or a
relative's house is okay this cruel
policy is designed to spread covid from
the University into the wild it won't
stop covid from spreading it makes no
sense as I talked about yesterday if you
have a kid at a college who's got
coveted let him spread it with a bunch
of young healthy people and maybe
they'll have the sniffles for a little
bit like they would with the flu you
don't send them to Grandma's house
you morons
all right we talked about Sanjay Gupta
but it turns out that every Cable News
Network has a Gupta I didn't know about
this Gupta but over on MSNBC they've got
a guide by the name of Vin Gupta you've
got to have a Gupta and here's bin Gupta
on the boosters and the rest of the
nonsense real quick if you will who
needs to get a booster and when
to all of us need boosters
um so if six months of Asian up we're
gonna have boosters by the end of this
month hopefully and those will protect
We Believe very strongly against these
new versions of the virus I think it's
possible that VIN Gupta might be the
worst Gupta he might be worse than
Sanjay Gupta this sounds like it's like
a Seinfeld episode doesn't it how many
guptas where
um six month olds getting coveted
vaccines no F in way my kids are not
being injected by that crap and the fact
that anyone in their right mind would
listen to these people but bringing this
back to what we talked about before what
was Tucker saying there's these people
they live in these big cities they've
sort of acquiesced to the machine they
they don't think for themselves they
turn on channels they're Democrat voters
so they turn on channels like MSNBC they
see Vin Gupta for some reason there's
something about having an Indian doctor
obviously that allows people to think
that this person is more relevant or
something like they've got a Gupta we've
got to get a Gupta
why would you listen to these people
anymore why don't I know you're watching
this so you won't but you should tell
someone else that you know that might be
listening to this nonsense about that
but it's not just coming back in the
media or in the schools it's coming back
at the white house because yes they are
now encouraging Americans to get updated
vaccines and it might be more coming
soon here's cringe Jean-Pierre
widely available at home covet test
wildly available effective treatments
which can reduce the risk of severe
illness hospitalizations and death we
will be encouraging as I have said
before Americans to get their updated
covid-19 vaccine in addition to their
annual flu shot and also RSV vaccine
no no I'm not getting the covid vaccine
I'm not getting the flu shot I don't
think I think maybe once about 25 years
ago I got the flu vaccine I think my mom
convinced me once right out of college
if I'm not mistaken and I'm not getting
the RSV vaccine I don't even know what
that is I'm not getting any of this I
don't care about your recommendations
and you should be embarrassed lady to
even have that job as we pointed out
yesterday Joe Biden Dr Jill Biden she's
a doctor she should have known better
she has tested positive for covid-19 so
then because of that and remember when
someone that you I assume that Dr Jill
Biden and the elderly man pretending to
be President Joe Biden I assume they
sleep in the same bed and he's ancient
right the guy's 164 years old with
dementia you would think that he would
have covet now apparently they're
telling us he does not have covid but
here's cringe Jean-Pierre once again on
what Joe Biden will be doing now that Dr
Jill Biden has coveted President Biden
tested negative last night for covid-19
and test it negative again today he's
not experiencing any symptoms as far as
the steps he is taking since the
president was with the first lady
yesterday he will be masking while
indoors and around people in alignment
with CDC guidance and he as as has been
the practice in the past the president
will remove his mask when sufficiently
distance from others indoors and while
outside as well
oh you're gonna love this guys so three
hours after that just after she said
that Joe Biden will be masking indoors
when he's around people he was given a
medal of honor ceremony to an army
captain and uh this guy's no youngster
either and there's several hundred
people in the room and here's Jill
[Applause]
do you get how insane this is you've got
cringe on Pierre saying he's gonna mask
he won't be inside with a lot of people
then they find the oldest man around
right they were like can we find
somebody older than Joe Biden they find
this guy God bless him thank you for
your service Semper Fi okay I don't not
making fun of this guy but then Joe
Biden's standing right next to him in
this room with people just after she
said they're gonna follow CDC guidelines
they of course don't follow the CDC
guidelines they want you to follow and
by the way uh Joe Biden actually left at
the wrong time he wasn't supposed to
walk out of the room at that point they
were about to do the prayers he just
wandered off
may God have mercy on our souls but
speaking of all of that we've got a
tweet from Alex Thompson about what
people are starting to come around when
uh it comes to Joe Biden new Wall Street
Journal poll 73 of Voters say they feel
that Joe Biden is too old to seek a
second term compared with 47 percent of
Voters who said the same of the 77 year
old Trump two-thirds of Democrats said
that Biden was too old to run again I
want to focus on the on the two-thirds
part for just a second two-thirds of
Democrats are saying it so if that's the
case if we're Wall Street Journal is
fairly reputable I would say in an age
when almost nothing is reputable
two-thirds of Democrats are saying this
guy is too old to do this again we all
see the wandering and the confusion and
everything else and yet they will not
put say a guy like RFK Jr who is polling
around 20 within the party they will not
let the Guy debate
what does that tell you about the
Machinery of the DNC I think you can
figure it out for yourself anyway
Democratic activist over on CNN Jake
Tapper had cringe Jean-Pierre on the
show yesterday to talk about Biden's age
and unpopularity
press Paul finds that most Americans
believe that President Biden is too old
to be president the poll looked at
80-year-old President Biden versus 77
year old Donald Trump 77 percent of
adults say Biden is too old to be
president 51 percent of adults say Trump
is too old and if you look at the
breakdown by Party Republicans generally
don't think of Trump's age as an issue
but both Democrats and Republicans agree
Biden is too old the thing that the
president is able to do is deliver
really move forward historic pieces of
legislation change the lives of
Americans for generations to come and
that is what we focus on the president's
worker in what he's been able to do look
people have come after the president
about his age they did it in 2019 they
did it in 2020 leading into the general
election and they they did it in 2022.
and guess what he beats them every time
because he has his finger on the pulse
of what it is that the American people
need he talks about issues that really
matter to the American people and he is
delivering is there more work to be done
there's always more work to be done but
we are happy to take that on certainly
not going to talk about 2024 but I what
I can speak to is what the president has
been able to deliver day after day for
the American people okay so you're part
of the 23 of adults who is not who are
not concerned about the president's
ability to be president because of his
age and stamina I got it
he has his finger on the pulse the man
barely has a pulse what are we doing
what are we doing of course she's just
giving you talking points right she's
nothing she's just like you could unzip
her and inside you would just see
nothing because she is just in service
to the machine everyone look it's not
specifically about the age okay it's
about the cognitive situation that
clearly has declined even just since
he's been president it was fairly
obvious to most of us before right when
he was running it was obvious to us when
he was vice president then we had four
years where he wasn't involved at all
then he starts running again and it was
obvious then they hopped him up on
Adderall or whatever else they do
remember then one debate his eye
exploded probably from the drugs like
who the hell knows what's going on there
in my estimation it's not purely about
the age like could you be 81 and highly
highly functional and capable of this
job I suppose that you could it's highly
unlikely but it ain't him that's the
obvious part even at 77 Trump like Trump
has clearly lost the step the way he
speaks the stilted repetitive nature of
a lot of this stuff like something is
not quite right there either it doesn't
mean that Trump is on his way to
dementia the way that Biden is but age
takes a toll on everybody there is a
difference between the way the average
23 year old acts and behaves and speaks
and the and the speed and the cognition
and the all of that versus the way the
average 83 year old does we all know
this now I want to throw back to uh to
Tucker Carlson and Dave Portnoy because
they talked about uh the Trump and Biden
age thing and something surprising came
up here to be honest I think both Trump
and Bina are too old I think there
should I don't think you should be able
to be that old and be president but I
think Trump
100 more aware I mean I I think Biden
has got some serious dementia issues oh
how that is the president I don't know
and that's not a Democrat because I said
about both it's like uh Mitch the guy
who had the stroke during the speech the
other day Mitch McConnell yeah like what
how power
these people running our country
I agree 100 that's the interesting thing
about that right like it's one thing for
Dave Portnoy to say okay Biden and Trump
are both old the fact that Tucker who is
largely in the Trump Camp of course
right I think he likes DeSantis too
that's fairly obvious and they had that
sit down right before I went off the
grid that was what middle of July uh
when they did that that conference with
the Blaze and Tucker sat down with all
of the candidates and and you could see
that clearly Tucker liked a lot of what
DeSantis was saying
um DeSantis by the way 45 years old if
I'm not mistaken uh but for Tucker to
say I agree 100 neither one of these
guys should be running because they're
too old that's pretty powerful as Brock
said as we showed you that clip uh it's
surprising that that clip didn't go more
viral because that's Tucker who's it
it's not that he's purely a trump
supporter as I'm saying but he is a
major mouthpiece for let's say the Mago
movement basically saying hey head of
Maga shouldn't even be running that is
that is pretty powerful but I also think
there's something else going on with
Trump right now you know obviously
there's all of the legal stuff happening
uh Trump is not out there remember he
always mocked Joe Biden uh for that
basement campaign right well Trump is
basically running a basement campaign
right now uh from Alex Thompson again AP
Trump has not campaigned for three weeks
now last appearing at the Iowa State
Fair on August 12th uh we could contrast
that by the way with DeSantis who is
going to all 99 counties in Iowa now
that's not purely based on age and I get
it Trump is distracted with the legal
stuff and all of that
um but maybe we are really seeing a
Changing of the Guard happening and it
it might be happening right in our faces
so what what can we do about all this I
didn't want to end the show on on a
purely
political version on a purely political
explanation of all of this uh I think
when you see this stuff the key is that
you don't become resentful of all of it
right like there's a lot of BS as I said
yesterday there's a lot of people that
will they'll bring it all back and
they'll ask for more the same people who
were duped last time will be duped again
you'll be disappointed by people people
who used to make sense will be
hysterical all of those things will
happen but I think the best thing that
you can do is not become obsessively
resentful and negative within all of
that and I saw this clip of Jordan
Peterson talking about that not from a
political perspective from a deeply
personal perspective but I think it
applies
here's hell
hell is when you get cancer
and then you're bitter and resentful
about it you make your last six months a
living nightmare and so you
might say well you've got cancer and
that sucks and no doubt it sucks and
maybe it's unfair and probably it is and
maybe even you know God and Satan
themselves bet against you
you're gonna aim up and maintain your
dignity and your integrity are you going
to take a bad situation and make it into
every goddamn nightmare you can possibly
imagine well of course you have to aim
up no matter what happens to you and you
think well that's not fair it's like
well it's better than the alternative
yeah and what does fair have to do with
it what's your choice you're gonna dig a
deeper pit
are you going to have some Integrity in
the face of life's catastrophe I think
we know the answer to that because when
you meet people who have integrity in
the face of catastrophe you're struck
with admiration for them yeah right
right so that's your heart speaking man
it's like I don't know how you do it but
you know I can't help but being
all right so we started the show by
talking about belief and that one way or
another human beings end up believing
and or worshiping something right and a
huge set of people unfortunately in a
largely modern secular world end up
worshiping government whether they
believe they do or not whether they
believe they believe it or not
what Jordan's talking about there is
something else what if in the face of
all of the madness that we continue to
face in our cultural Madness and our
political Madness hopefully you watching
this right now hopefully you're not
going through cancer hopefully you're
not going through some horrific personal
tragedy Health tragedy family tragedy or
something else let's just say the
tragedy is just everything confronting
our society right now right if that's
what it is the best way you can fight it
is with a little Integrity what if we
all decide you watching this and me
these guys in this room and and maybe
the rest of America what if we actually
all decided you know what the race to
the bottom is not the thing that we want
to do anymore we don't want to endlessly
destroy we don't want to endlessly lie
we don't want to endlessly ravage and
ransack this once great country we
actually want to try to do something
good well the best way you could do it
perhaps standing up straight with your
shoulders back and saying the truth that
is my plan that is what I will try to
continue to do I hope you will join me
on that Adventure if you have not
subscribed please do it rumble.com
Reuben report we've got a post game show
coming up in just moments at
reubenreport.locals.com oh and uh we've
got Governor DeSantis live at three
o'clock Eastern today on Rumble and
YouTube and locals uh we were going to
do it as I mentioned yesterday we were
going to do it in studio but because of
the hurricane his schedule got changed a
little bit but apparently there's some
big announcements coming from the
campaign today I actually don't know
what they are are but I know they wanted
to do this at three o'clock today so
that'll be live streamed just a bit
later and we leave you with the cold
clothes of a man that two-thirds of his
own party say he's too old to be
president
ciao
look uh and I want to thank a good
friend of mine Michigan governor
Gretchen Whitmer you've got a backbone
like a ramrod you know and of course
I know you've had an incredible role
model in America Lance bottoms she's got
a backbone like a ramrod the vice
president of the United States Vice
President Harris how's she doing you're
almost two years in she's doing great
she has a backbone like a ramrod but the
truth is she's the strongest person I
know she's a backbone like a ramrod I
see the world where I grew up like many
of you I grew up in Scranton as I said
my mom taught me
my mom had a backbone like a ramrod
[Music]